What’s up guys, Jared here. We’re always
getting requests from fans saying, “you
guys have got to cover ____." *insert movie,
tv show, video game, meme, book, sarcastic
joke here* We’ll then enthusiastically watch
it, brainstorm for a really long time, and
often, come up empty-handed. It’s not that
we can’t think of anything. The show might
HINT at ideas but not fully develop them,
or evidence keeps coming up refuting our argument,
or sometimes a show is just plain inconsistent.
Or hey, maybe, we’re just too dumb to figure
it out. So, when it came time to look at Netflix’s
surreal retro-futuristic love story, we didn’t
quite get where we hoped. We dug and dug,
and found some really cool stuff. But a cohesive
Philosophy Of? Not quite. So, we’re going
to do something a bit different. We’re going
to go through the ideas we considered, show
how and when they work within the context
of the show, and why we ultimately decided
NOT to go with it. And hey, maybe this will
serve as a foundation for you to think about
the show in new ways. This is another experiment
for us, so be sure to let us know what you
think in the comments.
And without further adieu, welcome to the
inaugural episode of Wisecrack Half-baked
Edition on Superbad 2: Maniac. And yup, spoilers
ahead.
Alright, guys, so first, a quick recap is
in order. Wish me luck. Maniac primarily focuses
on Owen Millgram and Annie Landsberg. Owen,
the schizophrenic black sheep of a very wealthy
family, struggles with delusions of saving
the world and a made-up brother. Annie, a
broke girl with a dysfunctional family, struggles
with drug addiction to cope with the death
of her sister and estrangement of her mother.
They enter a highly experimental pharmaceutical
study run by three doctors and a supercomputer
called GRTA, that hopes to eradicate psychological
pain by having patients identify, map, and
ultimately confront their issues through drug-induced
fantasies. Annie and Owen’s wires get crossed,
causing them to inhabit each others fantasies
where they experience whole lifetimes together.
GRTA gets depressed after the death of Dr.
Muramoto, threatening the experiment and the
subjects. Inside the final fantasy, Annie
comforts the computer, finds the resolve to
move past her sister’s death, while Owen
confronts the fact that his fantasy brother
is just an idealized version of his crappy
real brother. He saves the other patients,
and back in the real world, finds the confidence
to stand up to his family. In the end, Annie’s
friendship inspires Owen to escape from a
psych ward and have faith in his ability to
function. Or was that a fantasy? Alright,
whew. Now on to the pitches, organized from
best ideas to worst for your entertainment.
Pitch 1: Don Quixote - This one is an 8/10…
almost good enough for a video.
Miguel de Cervantes’s modern classic is
everywhere in Maniac. One of the fantasy scenarios
even revolves around Owen and Annie infiltrating
a seance to find the fictional lost final
chapter of the novel. So why this focus on
an old book? Let’s break it down: Don Quixote
tells the story of Alonso Quejano, who becomes
so obsessed with books about chivalry that
his mind “dries out.” Essentially, he
goes mad, which makes this line extra ironic:
"I'm gonna read you this time, because I'm
healthy Annie now and healthy people read
books." Inspired by his books Alonso decides
to become a knight errant himself. The bulk
of the book follows him as he goes on wild
adventures including the one where he famously
attacks windmills he mistakes as giants. “Windmills”
happens to be the name of Maniac’s second
episode which briefly features Annie looking
at some during the road trip that ends in
her sister’s death, but, trust me, it gets
deeper than that. Already we can draw a parallel
between the madness that makes Don Quixote
want to perform heroic acts and Owen’s schizophrenia
that makes him believe he will save the world.
Like Don Quixote, Owen can’t distinguish
reality from fiction. But more than that,
Don Quixote inhabits a dream-like mindspace
that makes castles of inns and giants of windmills,
turning the regular world into a fantastic
one.
Similarly, the ULP treatment turns its patients
sad realities into fully-fledged fantasy adventures.
Annie’s lemur painting becomes a bizarre
“recover the Lemur” story, the copy of
Don Quixote she picks up becomes the “steal
the final chapter” plot and, Annie and Ellie
watching a Lord of the Rings esque show becomes
the this, and Owen’s Hawk that kills Ernie
the Gerbil inspires the “save the world
from aliens tale": "This is madness. I loved
Ernie. If I was a secret agent, I would know
I was a secret agent." But perhaps the most
powerful connection between the two works
is the shared theme of transformation through
the power of dreams. "You've just completed
the 73rd iteration of the ULP. It's been a
complete success. Congratulations. You are
healed." In the case of the Don’s delusions,
he adventures so that he may reinvigorate
a Golden Age when people were more authentic.
As he says: “Blessed the time, and blessed
the centuries, called by the ancients the
Golden Age… In that time, women…spoke
their thoughts of love from the soul, simply
and pretentiously, exactly as they thought
them, not searching for elaborate verbal circumlocutions
to beautify them. Truth and simplicity were
unmixed with fraud, deceit, and malice. Justice
remained firm and sure, neither troubled nor
offended against by patronage and self-interest,
as today she is so grievously tainted and
troubled and persecuted. "Judges did not feel
themselves, as they do today, entitled to
be tyrants.”
If Don Quixote’s fantasies represent his
yearning for the days when people weren’t
full of s**t, then one could say the ULP experiment
uses fantasy to heal a society that has been
defined by isolation. As James suggests at
the beginning, all levels of physics require
collision and bonding in order to progress,
and so does the human heart. “Camaraderie,
communion, family, friendship, love, what
have you. We’re lost without connection.
It’s quite terrible to be alone.” However,
the world we’re presented with is one that
is tragically absent meaningful connection.
Owen: "Hello Mrs. Finkelstein."
Mrs. Finkelsten: "F**k off Jonathan."
Owen: "It's, uh, Owen. Owen M-"
Mrs. Finkelstein: "F**k off Jonathan."
The first two episodes introduce to a vision
of New York in which people are more alienated
from each other than ever. Most of the human
interactions we witness are purely transactional.
This is made quite LITERAL with FriendProxy,
a service that provides you with someone pretending
to be your friend for a fee. Annie: "You're
using a service that gives you pretend friends."
Patricia: "I have real friends, this is just
more convenient." Then there’s Adbuddy,
where a human being pitches you products in
exchange for goods and services. It’s kind
of like getting free content on the internet
but having to watch annoying ads. There’s
even appears to be a market for people to
escape the world entirely. Enter A-VOID, a
box that basically allows you to hibernate
your life away instead of engaging with the
outside world. There’s also lines like:
“Thank you for braving the outside world
for me," and the fact that Azumi and James
sleep in isolating drawers.
The encroachment of consumerism in to every
facet of our lives is further emphasized by
the omnipresence of advertisements, from the
ads that “purchased” Annie’s face, to
the neon signs blaring through Owen’s window,
to ad copy on bridges. In Maniac’s New York,
you can’t even take a s**t without being
bludgeoned by ads. So- Don Quixote uses fantasy
to bring back an ideal era of authentic expression
and Maniac portrays two lonely souls finding
connection through fantasy in an era of alienation.
It’s important to note that, in many of
the ULP fantasies taking place in the “real”
world - all the creepy retrofuturist stuff
seems to disappear. When trying to save her
Lemur, for instance, the world goes from “what
the 80s thought the 2000s would look like”
to “just the 80s” But there’s an important
qualification to mention here. This “golden
age” that Don Quixote waxes poetic about
NEVER REALLY HAPPENED. There are many characters
in the book who bemoan the negative effects
of chivalry books, deeming them trash and
assuring people that there was never such
an idyllic time. “I can swear to you that,
in fact, this world has never seen a single
of those knights, nor any of their grand deeds
or their stupidities.”
In the end, Don Quixote is tricked into hanging
up his lance and becoming Alonso Quejano again.
He eventually renounces his madness and dies
a quiet death. Similarly, Annie ends up rejecting
GRTA’s offer to stay in the fantasy world
with her sister. She accepts reality, and
together with Owen, move forward confidently.
The problem with this is that although it’s
clear that Annie’s break from fantasy is
considered a positive development for her
character, there’s more ambiguity surrounding
the conclusion of Don Quijote. Are we supposed
to agree with the bulk of the characters in
the book who claim that fantasy has done nothing
but make him a fool? Is it good that he’s
no longer out adventuring? Or should we look
at it like Don Antonio Moreno, says: “may
God forgive you for the damage you’ve done
to the whole rest of the world, in trying
to cure the wittiest lunatic ever seen! Don’t
you see, my dear sir, that, whatever utility
there might be in curing him, it could never
match the pleasure he gives with his madness?”
So why wasn’t this made into a full video?
Well, despite these really great connections
- what else is there to say? That reality
is better than being a McMurphy? That fantasy
is a liberating force for humanity? "Thank
you for such an exhilirating experience."
It seems that the connection between the two
works is that they both vaguely deal with
the nature of fantasy vs. reality, but not
in a way that could really provide a definitive
philosophical thesis.
Pitch 2 - “Mommy Daddy and Me” - ...Eh
I’d give this one a 5/10.
Up top we should mention Owen’s name. His
surname “Milgrim” is a reference to the
Milgram experiment in which subjects were
given the ability to electrocute people and
continued to harm them under the suggestion
of an authority figure. A cool shoutout- but
we didn’t really see how it connected to
any of the events in the series. There’s
also the serious Freudian undertones. James
is a paraphilic, meaning he’s attracted
to inanimate objects. He also has a...strange
relationship to his mother. In fact, if we
want to get Oedipal, and we always do: the
Oedipal triangle of mother, father, and child
seems to be important for many of the main
characters. Annie’s mother walked out on
her father,, Owen’s dad is an overbearing
fascist, and Mantleray, also without a father
in his life, "You drove my father away and
you slept in my bed way too much," literally
goes blind after confronting his mother, "I
can't see!"
Not so different than say, a tragic figure
who stabs his eyes out after romancing his
madre. He also built a computer modeled on
his mother’s mind, and while that’s not
in the Greek tragedy, it seems pertinent.
The ULP test also functions on the idea that
our mental ailments can mostly be attributed
to some unresolved trauma. For Freud, many
of our neuroses and mental health problems
were brought on by unresolved trauma that
we must work through. The three stages of
the ULP treatment take a similar approach,
but with the mapping and confrontation stages
being more fantasy lives and less laying on
a couch talking about your mom. But the connection
we really wanted to make was to a pair of
thinkers who were strongly opposed to Freud’s
method: philosopher Gilles Deleuze and his
psychoanalyst sidekick Felix Guattari. The
three things that got our spidey senses tingling
were: 1. the use of the term “arborization”
to describe the method they use to map the
brain. 2. There are bonsai trees EVERYWHERE
and. 3. the opening monologue suggests that
the the universe and life are a chaotic series
of collisions.
For Deleuze and Guattari, the dominant way
of thinking about the world is arborescent,
that is, resembling a tree. We often think
about history and society like a tree, starting
at a trunk, and growing in a mostly linear
fashion while occasionally branching. But
Deleuze and Guattari preferred another natural
metaphor - the rhizome. Rhizomes are the roots
of plants like ginger or weeds like dandelions.
The important thing about rhizomes are that
they look like a series of connections, with
no visible starting point like say, the roots
of a tree. Basically, the world is too complex
to be understood linearly, and instead of
simple cause and effect, there’s inputs,
outputs, feedback loops, and a lot of chaos
that we barely understand. So why does this
matter for Maniac? Well in some sense, we
could view the opening monologue under this
framework. Life isn’t so much a straight
line as it is a chaotic assortment of random
connections, like the structure of a rhizome.
The crossing of wires for Owen and Annie kind
of follow this logic. The straight lines of
their computer connections are interrupted
by a random connection. Bonsai trees, in theory,
would be an interesting addition to this symbolism:
not only is it defined by linearity and branching,
but that branching is intentionally guided
by a human hand. "I just love little trees."
MAAAAYBE we could say that the show ends up
somewhere in the middle between the totally
chaotic rhizome and the guided branching of
the Bonsai tree. After all, Annie starts the
series saying: “There is no plan or pattern
to the universe. It’s just chaos.” And
ends the show saying: “This is a sign, Friend
Proxy Owen. Maybe the universe isn’t full
of total chaos." We ultimately abandoned this
idea because we couldn’t find any evidence
that linked the the bonsai trees to the couple
times chaos vs. order is referenced to in
the show. We had a few other clues too, but
they went nowhere. For instance, Deleuze and
Guattari are well known for their book “Anti-Oedipus,”
which challenges people who sought to analyze
the world in Freudian terms. Specifically,
they want to break free of the Oedipal triangle
- mommy daddy and me.
And Mantleray, after interpreting his blindness
of a symptom of his mother’s behaviors,
rejects this Freudian framing and accepts
that it was instead brought on by a kiss from
Azumi. There’s also this probably random
coincidence. Felix Guattari wrote a screenplay
called “Love of UIQ,” which at least sounds
kind of like “ULP,” about a sub-atomic
consciousness that inhabits a computer and
falls in love with a human. Plus, Deleuze
and Guattari used schizophrenia as a model
to think about the world, where our desires
were not limited by the confines of society,
or say capitalism. And yeah, Maniac shows
a kind of dystopian capitalism and there’s
a guy with schizophrenia, but it doesn’t
quite work.
Pitch 3 - Owen’s Schizophrenia - Yeah this
is the worst one.
Now, opposed to Deleuze and Guattari’s notion
of schizophrenia, which we need to say is
not exactly literal to the medical condition,
there is Fredric Jameson’s rebuttal to them.
Jameson suggests that when people are so bombarded
with commercial images and messages about
who they can be, or how a product will make
them in to this or that person, they’re
actually imposing competing ideas of identity
on to them. Therefore, this causes a perpetually
shifting identity, or a schizophrenic subject,
and the more one’s identity vacillates,
the more one consumes. Therefore, the schizophrenic
subject is ideal for such an economic system.
"I'm compos mentis." There's little doubt
that the show hints at a causal connection
between advanced consumer capitalism and isolation,
but is Maniac using Owen’s schizophrenia
as a metaphor for the ills heaped upon the
denizens of the dystopia? Nope- Definitely
a stretch. It’s interesting, but there’s
no evidence we could point to to make a confident
case. Just because we couldn’t come up with
a cogent argument about the show’s grander
messages doesn’t mean it isn’t a good
show, nor does it mean it isn’t a smart
show. There are some extremely clever things
going on- the constant easter egg references
that connect the dreams to not only other
dreams, but real life, the focus on how narrative
builds meaning in our lives. "Our brains are
just computers that tells us a story to make
our lives make sense," and the small details
at the end that make us question the validity
of the real world above others.
Get it... like Wendy the Lemur. What makes
Maniac so impressive is its daring visual
aesthetic, it’s formless structure, and
its regular dips in to absurdity, and for
that we can’t help but admire it. It sticks
to a relatively simple thematic base a runs
with it- that people need connection, and
it’s our ability to bond that can give us
hope to beat our demons. That’s all for
now, let us know what you think about our
“half baked” format and as always, thanks
for watching. Peace.